à
[Musique]
bonjour à tous nos amis à poils et à
plumes c'est miss plume il suit à vos
nombreux commentaires très positifs nous
nous retrouvons pour un deuxième épisode
de kick effet la bestiole aujourd'hui je
vous propose d' aiguiser vos capacités
d'apprentis éthologue grâce à un oiseau
qui s'est porté le noir comme un pro les
great ardoise et les aigrettes sont des
oiseaux très élancée souvent blanc est
généralement inféodés aux points d'eau
en france nous avons deux espèces des
great toutes les deux blanches les great
garzette avec son bec noir et la grande
aigrette avec le bec jaune voire noir et
jaune en fonction de la période de
l'année
l'espèce qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
les great ardoisé est une espèce
africaine et elle fait montre d'un
comportement très particulier car pour
ce qu'ont lancé
c'est le seul oiseau à agir de la sorte
les aigrettes qu'on trouve en france ne
se comportent pas du tout de la même
manière sans plus attendre
voyons donc ce que fait cet oiseau
et à présent c'est à vous de jouer
essayez de deviner à quoi sert cet
étrange parapluie de plumes alors je
vais procéder comme pour la dernière
fois je vais vous proposer un petit
quizz et vous allez pouvoir choisir la
réponse qui vous paraît la plus
appropriée
la question est donc et qui fait la
bestiole petits tas c'est le meilleur
moyen de se protéger des prédateurs ni
vu ni connu petit b ils essaient de
pénétrer sur le territoire d'une autre
et grèce en douce son déguisement de le
parapluie est absolument parfait petit c
il imite le parasol d'un touriste il
fait beaucoup trop chaud en afrique pour
rester tête nue surtout quand qu'on
porte du noir petit décès sa technique
de pêche secrètes les martins pêcheurs
n'ont qu'à bien se tenir
donc réfléchissez bien et moi pendant ce
temps je vous remets la vidéo
comme je vous le dit la dernière fois
prenez en compte l'environnement de
l'animal
essayez de voir vers quoi il dirige son
regard généralement les oiseaux ont
tendance à fixer ce qui les intéresse en
glaucome nous donc penser à bien étudier
à la fois loiseau et ceux qui
l'entourent et c'est un tout
et nous revoilà donc devant ce quiz si
vous avez besoin d'un peu plus de temps
pour réfléchir
n'hésitez pas à mettre la vidéo en pause
maintenant car moi je vais passer aux
résultats là pas de réponse était donc
là des c'est sa technique de pêche
secrète
bravo à ceux qui avaient trouvé ce quiz
était un peu plus compliqué que celui de
la dernière fois mais il y avait tout de
même quelques indices pour vous mettre
la puce à l'oreille
le premier c'est lorsqu'on voit le bec
de l'oiseau taper brusquement l'eau à
plusieurs reprises alors qu'il est caché
sous ses ailes en réalité il harponne
les petits poissons qui passent à sa
portée
souvenez vous tue vous ai dit qu au
début de la vidéo que les great ardoisé
est un oiseau qui vit principalement
près de l'eau ici vous en doutiez la
forme de son bec nous renseigne sur son
régime alimentaire mais beck l'on est
droit comme celui de les great sont
souvent utilisés comme de véritables
harpon pour pêcher on retrouve avec deux
formes similaires chez le martin pêcheur
mais aussi chez les sternes par exemple
[Musique]
non
lundi suivant c'est que les grecs n'est
ni poursuivis ni inquiète
il n'y a pas d'autres animaux à
proximité elle ne semble pas se soucier
de quoi que ce soit et enfin le dernier
indice c'est bien évidemment que
l'oiseau fixe l'eau en se déplaçant en
l'occurrence il s'intéresse à son futur
repas les poissons en règle générale les
oiseaux ont tendance à fixer les choses
auxquelles ils s'intéressent un peu
comme nous en fait si un bruit nous
attire le rail vers la droite
notre regard va suivre si on est
concentré sur un livre notre regard sera
fixé sur la page pour lui il vient les
oiseaux c'est pareil si un bruit attire
leur attention ils vont tourner la tête
vers la source du bruit s'ils sont en
train de s'inquiéter du fait que le chat
du voisin avancent dans leur direction
leur regard sera braquée sur le matou et
s'ils sont en pleine séance de pêche et
bien et n'ont d'yeux que pour leurs
proies
ce comportement avec les ailes formant
comme un parapluie il vraiment
spécifique de les great ardoisé mais à
quoi ça sert eh bien
plusieurs raisons en premier ça annule
la réflexion naturel de l'eau qui
perturbe la vision l'oiseau c'est pas
facile de savoir exactement où se trouve
le poisson lorsque l'eau agit comme un
miroir
ensuite en adoptant cette posture les
grecs créer une sorte de pénombre dans
l'eau qui attire les poissons en leur
faisant croire qu'ils pourront s'y
cacher donc les greta plus de chances
qu'un poisson reste près d'elle si elle
étend ses ailes
c'est un sacré avantage pour la pêche et
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
si vous avez des idées de vidéos à
traiter laissez-moi les liens dans les
commentaires et je les ajouterait à la
liste de celles que j'ai déjà et qui
sait ce sera peut-être le sujet du
prochain qui fait la bestiole
à bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
avec des plumes
[Musique]